[Music]
no viewers are gonna be sad to see
blackroll magic already busted up
no blackroll magic will never be busted
up it lives on but I was really excited
to you know be able to meet someone who
I had such a very different perspective
of and get to know her heart and get to
see a very different side of her so
she's gonna carry I told her I said you
gotta you gotta got a handle it for me I
can't be here I'll be there in spirit
but make me proud he's a numbers guy he
wants to outdo his predecessors can I
just say this as bad as I think Trump is
you would be worried about pence
Omarosa shocked houseguests and has
shocked the world with some of the
things she said in the house about her
time in the White House hearing her get
so candid about that time and sharing
her thoughts now what was your takeaway
from that you know everyone has their
truth and all of the experiences that we
have in life are what helped make us who
we are so you know she's a tough girl
and she's accomplished so much in her
life a tough woman not a girl she's a
tough woman and she's accomplished a
whole lot in her life and I'm really
grateful and I'm happy to see the
journey and the transition that she has
made and you know we're always evolving
we're always growing we're always
changing and she seems to have really
learned a lot and it's helped kind of
set her moral compass and just her
compass in terms of things outside her
and her greater responsibility as a
woman on this planet so I'm happy for
her for that
we're seeing a whole new Omarosa whole
new Omarosa I did the dirty work of
Shannon you were not my choice well you
were our choice let me be honest you
were our choice however know that this
is not an alliance
just know that you had some words for
James about Shannon why make that
statement I made that statement because
Shannon is really wreaking havoc in the
house she is telling so many lies to so
many different people and I get its big
brother but I feel like you also have to
be accountable for what you do
and I had nothing to lose like James
knew it wasn't gameplay it wasn't I had
nothing to lose or I had no advantage to
giving him that information so I hope
that he heeds the warning because he's
kind of teamed up with her and he has no
clue what's what's in for him and I
really also wanted to say it for the
whole house so they could really see the
reality of the situation in a person's
position who I'm not I'm not a threat to
you winning this game well there was a
plan that didn't play out in the end to
backdoor Shannon this week yeah
reaction to that yes you know I hope
that's why I gave that little bit at the
end because I wanted to give them the
ammunition that they need to get Shannon
out because if they don't shannon is
gonna bulldoze over every last one of
them and they won't even see it coming
[Music]